something i will never forget about  stanford is amazingly the children of my  classmates  during the year and moments where things  get a bit hectic uh  the smiles of these kids faces is often  like the brightest moment of my week  something i never forget about the msx  program is welcoming the  fifth member of our family  right here on campus at the stanford  hospital  so christopher was born literally one  month into the program he's been the  little msx baby it was just really took  a lot of the stress out of the whole  experience of welcoming a new member  into the family we have christopher our  our  the baby that was born this year and  it's just so fun first of all to watch  my classmate his parents  show up like days after he was born and  it just shows like how important this  family is to each other and also like  how fun to pass a baby around at the  barbecues and so he just brings like joy  and and levity to the year